there been reports over the weekend that
the government has drawn up a
three-stage plan for ending the lockdown
which includes potentially opening
schools from the 11th of May some
non-essential retail businesses and then
allowing small gatherings by the end of
the month
now of course I know there are huge
caveats here nothing has been decided
but is that correct no it's not it is
the case that we are looking at all of
the evidence but we've set some tests
which need to be passed before we can
think of easing restrictions in this
lockdown it's very important when we're
still in the process of making sure that
we can reduce the rate of infection and
also reduce the number of deaths that we
maintain the steps that we have now of
course we're looking at the data it is
the case that the rate of infection
appears to be flattening but we do not
want to take steps to early because the
most important thing is to make sure
that the NHS and the public's health is
protected you can tell that people agree
with that assessment that's why so many
people are obeying the lockdown staying
at home to try and protect the NHS but
if we're looking at a kind of road map
if you like out of the lockdown which
many people would like to see it's been
difficult and period for many people are
already is it right the broad-brush
direction for example that schools and
nurseries may be one of the earliest
things to open no I think it would be
wrong to get ahead of ourselves here it
is the case that if we managed to ensure
that the rate of infection is kept low
if we can see the rate of deaths falling
if we can make sure that the NHS is
capacity is as strong as it can be then
we can think about some of the steps we
may be able to take in order to release
some of the restrictions that are
already in place but the important thing
is that we're guided as we have been
throughout by the facts and by the
scientific advice that we receive and
the facts and the advice are clear at
the moment that we should not be
thinking of lifting these restrictions
yet clearly coming through that the
timing of this is something that is
still being looked at that
nothing is going to change yet but is it
not fair to say what could change even
if you can't say when it would change
people are smart enough to realize that
they have to stay home now but they may
look to asking the government about what
the plan is in a few weeks time or a few
months time entirely understandable of
course that that there should be a
public debate about how we approach
these difficult choices but the most
important thing to do is to make sure
that we proceed in a way that's
discarded by science and one of the
things that we need to have are all the
facts all the data in front of us to
know what would be appropriate to do and
at what time so the steps that we've
introduced have been determined by the
advice that we've received from the
government scientific advisory group for
emergencies and they and others are
looking at the the facts that we have
now and it's on the basis of those facts
that we will then say what we believe is
the the right process and the right
timescale for easing these restrictions
and I appreciate obviously that if we're
thinking in due course of particular
settings coming back and operating we
needed to make sure that those settings
have time to prepare absolutely but it
is also the case that we need to make
sure that when those settings do come
back whatever the appropriate area of
our life our public likely it is that
has the restrictions eased it's also
important that we bear in mind what the
the new situation might be in those
settings because one of the things that
we've learnt from this this new and
deadly virus is that after we ease
restrictions in some areas there will
still be a need for discipline in others
and we need to make sure that the
approach that we take is informed by the
science and that the measures on social
distancing and on protecting individuals
particularly public sector workers are
appropriate looking about being guided
by the evidence and the science and the
number of people dying is still
breathtakingly high of course but are
you hopeful that we may be past the peak
well you're absolutely right only one of
the things that is deeply worrying and
concerning is still the high level of
debts and
as you've reported and recorded as we
know every single death is the loss of
her a loved one will cause grief and
heartache for families across the
country and it's precisely for that
reason that we we don't want to lift
restrictions before we can be confident
that we're in a position where it's safe
to do so now the evidence suggests that
the rate of infection and the death rate
is flattening but we're not absolutely
certain that we have yet on a downward
trajectory and we want to be heading
towards that downward trajectory to be
confident about all the steps that we
might want to take I want to ask you
about the prime minister who of course
they're still recovering at Chequers how
is he and is he going to be doing any
work in the coming weeks
well the prime is just recovering well
he's in cheerful spirits and he had the
opportunity to talk to Dominic rob his
deputy the first Secretary of State on
Friday and the prime minister's
instructions here to the rest of us in
government were communicated by the
first secretary of state when we had a
conference call yesterday morning so
it's good that the prime minister is
recovering he's following of course the
advice of his his his doctors in order
to make sure that he rests recovers
fully but he's absolutely on top of
things and it's it's I think the wish of
all of us that the promise was restored
to full health as quickly as possible
now I'm keen to move on to some of the
criticisms that the government responds
to copa90 now as well and new supplies
of personal protective equipment have
arrived in the UK today after health
care workers were told that they may
have to reuse gowns because of global
shortage can you guarantee that those
people now on the front line risking
their lives for all of us will now have
the protective equipment that they need
going forward yes it's the first
priority of government and of my
colleague Matt Hancock and I to ensure
that we protect those on the front line
who are doing so much to keep the rest
of us safe it is the case that there's a
consignment of personal protection
equipment that's arriving from
which contains tens of thousands of guns
it's also the case that we have a deal
with China in order to bring in due
course some twenty five million guns
over to the United Kingdom in order to
make sure that people are kept safe
gangs of the area at the moment where
there is the greatest need but we also
need to make sure that people have the
appropriate face masks which allow them
to operate in in the these clinical
settings and also that people have the
visors and the gloves and the other
protective equipment that they need and
today law Dayton who was responsible for
the the organizational success of the
Olympics in 2012 has agreed to lead the
task force which is making sure that we
have all the personal protective
equipment that people need in the
National Health Service in care settings
and also more broadly in the public
sector it's interesting to hear that
protective equipment is coming to the UK
from China because according to a report
in The Sunday Times the opposite thing
happened a couple of months ago is a
pretty damning investigation by the
paper saying that the government lost
five weeks in the fight against
coronavirus by missing those early
warning signs and despite low levels of
protective equipment in the UK by late
February the UK had sent 266 thousand
pieces of protective equipment to China
is that correct well there are one or
two aspects of the Sunday Times report
that are slightly off being but the most
important thing distress is that the
fight against the coronavirus is an
international effort so of course we
think what do you think Chinese
government and with other governments
but one of the things that we have done
is to make sure in advance of this so
what do you think correct in these
Sunday Times appointee to interrupt
whatever great point by I won't go
through here a point-by-point rebuttal
of all of the things in the Sunday Times
story that are you know a little bit off
beam but that will be that will be done
later but the most important thing to
bear in mind is that the personal
protection equipment stocks in this
country were built up in anticipation of
a flu pandemic they were supplemented as
a result of our planning for a No Deal
brexit and
it's also the case that we've been
collaborating with other countries
including China not just on making sure
that we can have the personal protective
equipment that people need but also that
we have the ventilator capacity that
people need and we're also collaborating
as the business secretary pointed out on
Friday in worldwide effort to try to
secure a vaccine for this virus okay and
it was a really really simple question
is it correct that by late February the
UK sent 266 thousand pieces of
protective equipment to China I won't
get into a detailed to-and-fro on the
Sunday Times story more details will be
yes I'm not going to get into it now
I explained that I'm going to ensure
we're going to ensure that an
appropriate response to the Sunday Times
story is issued later okay and so people
don't deserve to know whether or not we
did send hundreds of thousands of pieces
of protective equipment to China in
February I think it's important that we
share facts in a transparent way and
those facts will be shared later today
at the British health care trades
Association rich represents 500
companies claims in the Sunday Times it
was ready to supply protective equipment
for two months but it's offered to help
the NHS wasn't accepted until April the
first is that correct well they've been
a number of organizations that have
sought to provide us with personal
protective equipment and we're grateful
to all of them
and there has been a united national
effort in order to make sure that
personal protective equipment has both
been procured from abroad and also
manufactured at home but again I'm not
going to go through each individual
application from each individual
organization because there are details
behind the processing of each
application that are sensitive to each
firm and to each country okay and let's
move on to testing see if we can get any
answers when it comes to testing as well
and people again very concerned about
the level of testing done in the UK the
British in vitro diagnostics Association
which represents lots of companies
making up the UK's testing sector said
it didn't receive a meaningful approach
from the government until April the
first of course that's the
day before that Hancock announced the
hundred thousand a day target is that
true or is that something that's off
being well again when it comes to our
approach towards testing it is the case
that the Department of Health and Social
Care have been in touch with a range of
organizations both public and private
sector in order to ensure that we can
increase the number of tests in this
country we now have capacity to test
thirty-eight thousand people a day and
we're on course to be able to test a
hundred thousand people a day by the end
of this month but again each individual
organization that has approached the
government with offers of help has been
responded to and dealt with in a
particular fashion and it would gate it
would again be wrong for me to go
through each individual offer at this
stage because there are factors
governing each of those approaches which
are specific to each company to each
offer and to each test and just it's
interesting to hear you say that we're
on course to meet that hundred thousand
target by the end of the month is that
really true because it does feel as if
that's a very long way to go still yes
we are on course to meet that hundred
thousand target as I say and we have the
capacity to do thirty-eight thousand
tests that's a significant increase on
where we work when we lost one hundred
thousand or a hundred thousand tests
well we want to make sure that every
test that people are capable of taking
is being taken but you are right to draw
attention to the fact that we have the
capacity to provide tests to people but
not all of those tests have been taken
out and that's why the health secretary
has ensured that test capacity is now
being extended beyond frontline NHS and
social care workers to others in the in
the public sector and other key workers
as well because we want to make sure
that having generated this additional
capacity and I must thank those who've
been involved in public health England
the NHS and others in the amazing
efforts that they've made in order to
increase this number we must make sure
of course that the additional test
capacity is used in the most efficient
way possible crystal clear that and is
that target now to have a capacity of a
hundred thousand tests by the end of the
month or to actually be carrying out a
hundred thousand tests
a hundred thousand tests delivered being
carried out by the end of the month now
we've been talking about and being
behind other countries and being perhaps
slow to act in some ways one areas where
some people are surprised that we
haven't done more on is they're wearing
face masks we've seen other countries
recommend people wearing face masks that
went out in public situations do you
think the UK government advice could
change on that well the advice will come
from our scientific advisors the the the
clear evidence is that a in certain
clinical settings as you know face masks
are absolutely vital but we also need to
reflect on whether or not it would be
appropriate and our medical and
scientific advisers have said this to
extend the use of other types of face
masks in other settings but it would be
wrong for me to to jump the gun and to
anticipate what the scientific advice
would be they the best way to proceed on
on these questions is to have our
scientists and our doctors look at the
evidence advise government and then
government make a decision on the basis
of that independent advice flights
entering the country as well because
again other countries have been Swift in
the nars to knock down on international
flights to impose quarantines have we
been too slow and is that something that
we're looking at - I don't think so no
and I can understand this is a live area
of public debate but one of the things
that we do need to make sure is that we
get flights into this country carrying
precisely the components that we've just
been discussing it is the case that in
order to make sure that we have personal
protective equipment that we have the
ingredients for testing that we have
everything that's needed at the front
line that we need to have flights coming
into this country it's also the case
that we're repatriating British citizens
from abroad and it's appropriate that
they come in but I do think it's a fair
point to say that we we do need to think
about border controls overall the advice
that we've had again from our scientists
and doctors is that none of the flights
coming in or the volume of aviation
traffic that we've had will have had a
significant deleterious effect on the
spread of the disease but again that's
something
be kept under review my own view is that
we should follow the scientific advice
we should heed their call to ensure that
we get the equipment that we need but as
with everything when you have a new
virus which poses new challenges you
have to keep things under review
listening I just can't help feeling as
if it looks like we're always playing
catch-up we thought we had enough
protective equipment then we realized we
didn't we didn't think testing was a
priority now we do we're trying to scale
it up rapidly we're still reviewing the
evidence on face mask we're still
looking at international travel why is
it that we seem to have acted more
slowly than other countries well the
first thing to say is on personal
protective equipment we did have good
stocks and those stocks have built up
partly to deal with the pandemic flu
pandemic partly because of the
experience of preparing for a no
deal-breakers well that's what I'm
telling you we did have those stop
suddenly built them up it is the case
that with testing we've always
recognized its importance and we've been
making sure that we can develop five
pillars in order to ensure that we can
have a range of tests appropriate to the
circumstances and it is the case that
when it comes to areas like the the
wearing of masks we've been looking at
the scientific evidence but it comes
back to to our very first sort of stage
of this conversation when you were quite
rightly probing and asking when will
certain restrictions be lifted and I
said that we wanted to follow the advice
and to only proceed when the scientific
advice was clear there is a temptation
of course to act and to act in certain
circumstances because of you know
understandable pressure from
commentators and elsewhere but our
approach is to be guided by the science
and to move in a way which is not a
knee-jerk but considered but at the same
time it is the case that there is urgent
active and energetic work across the NHS
across the scientific community and
across government in order to ensure
that where their science is clear where
our action needs to be urgently we're
taking it which is why we have
to increase the number of ventilators in
the NHS and bring new ventilators online
it's why were increasing our testing
capacity and it's why also we are making
sure that as well as bringing PPE from
abroad we're also increasing our
capacity to manufacture it at home okay
now in the Sunday Times today they
claimed that Boris Johnson skipped five
meetings on coronavirus the meetings of
Cobra the emergency committee an unnamed
senior Downing Street adviser is quoted
in the newspaper saying there's no way
you're at war if your Prime Minister
isn't there and what you learn about
Boris walls he didn't share any meetings
he liked his country breaks he didn't
work weekends there was a real sense
that he didn't do urgent crisis planning
it was exactly like people feared he
would be now back in 2016 you withdrew
your support for Boris Johnson's
leadership bit saying he cannot provide
the leadership or build the team for the
task ahead given what you've seen in the
last few months were you right or wrong
about that totally wrong the the point I
mentioned earlier that they the Sunday
Times story was had one or two off beam
elements to it
this I think is the one that some
wildest off beem the idea that the Prime
Minister skipped meetings that were
vital to our response to the coronavirus
I think is grotesque the truth is that
the there are meetings across government
some which are chaired by the health
secretaries on which are chaired by
other ministers but the Prime Minister
took all the major decisions and I think
anyone who considered what happened to
the prime minister just a little while
ago nobody can say that the practice
throwing heart and soul into fighting
this virus his leadership has been clear
it's been inspirational at times and I
think that actually nothing is more off
beam than the suggestion the Prime
Minister was anything other than an
energetic determined focused and strong
in his leadership against this virus